we're gonna use the number 1 so you can
make another subtract numbers on the
number line okay so yes question I
spending more time trying to figure how
you'd stop I like you to draw a bunch of
number lines for me put some space
between them
now hopefully you go straighter than
mine because I did my freedom because I
didn't have a ruler in this room but
that's joy three three will be enough to
know now what's the most important
number on the number line it's always
zero zero because that tells you where
ever you thing else is in relation to it
right we always tend to put it in the
middle struck the first one well let's
see I reckon 10 centimeters hopefully
that'll get my stage
other squares are there Hoffa I would
you need to get because then you can do
double to square screen so wait a minute
4-2 but we're gonna do it on the novel
I'm gonna show it okay all right now
you've got zero Dan sorry
let's have a go at this way now that for
that means we're gonna start at four
okay so make sure you've got full label
there and then we're gonna go to the
left two units so this is the way that I
work
so that's minus two
so wherever I ended up well because
that's for I could label woman rest of
them one two three so that's why I end
on to never rush but it's really nice to
be able to illustrate that there another
do let's switch it around to minus four
so where shall we stop where you stop at
a festive addiction maybe I should not
label that there stop there
okay this too now when I am subtracting
four just like with my first question
I'm gonna go that way so I need a few
more markings so I want to draw in my -
okay so being that we're to the left of
zero that means that numbers not very
positive it's gonna be negative and it's
two units that way so it's minus two
all right let's do this - one more okay
now be careful
you remember just like over here this
second example um we're trying to make
sure you read this carefully so how
would we read is help we actually write
up the words well I would say and maybe
you would read this as well with me I
would say negative three because that's
the first integer what's the operation
it's - in this case - negative two
okay now you sometimes hear this called
a double dated you okay you could sort
of see what they're getting at but
that's not really right is it why not
why isn't it a double negative
yeah yeah we've got a verb and adjective
whereas a double logic double adjective
isn't actually in there yes all right so
where are we gonna start wherever you
start we can stop at the minus three so
that's the first stop but they give us
here's minus three
now when you have that minus there okay
you're facing to the left but then they
say negative two so you've faced back to
the right so you're going this way
as a big confusing isn't it so I miss
this this was minus 4 this is minus
negative 2 and that's why you can see
we're still to the left of 0 often
called the origin and we're 1 unit to
the left so that's why it's minus 1 now
using the number line as a way to
illustrate subtractions we really really
useful there's a bit time-consuming
eventually you'll get used to doing it
in your head but this is a really
helpful tool to use and the question I
got was I didn't get this one this is
confusing that's why I was the last one
I did lost
okay so let's dwell on having wall now
which part is confusing
I think it's confusing because there are
so many why this is a mechanism that's a
bit weird so what I want us to put down
is let's write that down
I need some more space
like it sir I'm gonna try a bit bigger
and maybe if you're struggling with
understanding sati maybe you want to do
the same as well and we're gonna label
all these pieces and hopefully once we
do that understand it better we'll see
what's going on sure negative 3 that's
what's going on negative 3 is where I
started see that I started at negative 3
so that's my starting point if you like
and the first number will always be your
sign point okay and that's always where
you begin yeah if I put something in the
board I think it's dead are they gonna
do
and it's always easier to have extra
stuff that you don't need you can say I
don't worry about that versus who knew
it
they explain this thing in the comic
remember and then your hands down um and
Kairi room so I think it's better to
write more all right now what's right
there in the middle what's in the middle
is this guy so this operation the first
thing it does is it tells you I want you
to move I want you to go somewhere I
don't want you to stay here I want you
to move off in some direction and which
direction is to find you by which
operation it is okay question I'm just
just potty okay so a plus or a minus
it means move right in a certain
direction for - which direction is it
it's moved to the left that's the way we
that's the way we've described it okay
because that's what L don't know it
looks like all the negatives are there
all right so we started yeah or anything
you could kick we're gonna move to the
left you're that way and then you get
this guy right so this is negative - now
hold on a second
rippen we started at negative three
which side of zero where we are we're on
the left side what we so negative on its
own it kind of means to the left so
therefore when you see negative two
right that means that how much are you
going to move to the left well the
distance will be two that the direction
is going to be not left anymore
it's like to the left and then sorry
which one less is this way for you guys
okay so to the left and then to the left
again which is why would I drew it I
went eventually to the right so I'm
turning around twice if you like it
isn't quite two wrongs make a right but
it's the same kind of idea if you're
getting confused by the left right
business maybe you want to think about
it as forward and backward
hold it backwards so I could call this
okay we're backwards right just like
okay I'll move back at the turn around
but then this number tells you I can go
backwards again so backwards backwards
is forwards isn't it this is this is me
going forwards okay so plus okay hold a
second if I go backwards backwards okay
so instead of going that way backwards -
backwards is forward so I'm still going
in the same direction I'm still going
toward the right which is by the way why
the area so you can show yeah you can
think about as retaining if you like
it's like either do you turn and then I
did and you turn again and now I'm
headed in the same direction than I was
in the beginning so yes I'm okay so
therefore moving backwards negative two
is the same as moving forwards positive
two so these two this minus sign is
negative come together like this
you see that the lattice of the negative
together they give you an addition sign
they kind of cancel each other out
that's how I read my street boat over to
the right to you
it's good question is that open clear
off is that any better
smell there with keeping it through one
more question
that's exactly right the Averys rule not
minus one